- To be self-aware of what they
actually have to add to the conversation.
Being a personal brand for the sake
of being a personal brand is usually
the quickest way to not
be a personal brand.
(pumping rock music)
- You have quite the time limit.
- Okay.
- So we'll jump right in yeah?
- Please.
- I'm just going to record this.
- No worries.
- Okay.
So Gary Vaynerchuk is known for hustle.
- So talk to me what
does hustle mean to you?
Why is it important?
- For me it's important because
I don't think any of us in this room
or anybody reading this
article can physically
change how smart they are.
I don't think we can make
ourselves more clever
or more strategic,
but I do think that hard work is the
most controllable aspect of
entrepreneurship and business
that anybody can deploy.
And I find that fascinating.
Right, it's very hard for us to be born
with more physical attributes,
but if we work out seven days a week
we can be more athletic
we can be stronger.
I think work ethic aka hustle
is that same version in business it's
the most controllable and I try to give
advice that is actually
practical not makes me look cool.
So that's why I love hustle.
- Very nice.
So the personal brand is something
you speak on a lot it's something
that social media has really
become possible for everyone.
So what's the first step for someone
to build that great personal brand?
- To be self-aware of what they actually
have to add to the conversation.
You know being a personal brand for the
sake of being a personal brand is usually
the quickest way to not
be a personal brand.
I think you have to
understand what you do,
what you talk about.
I mean I talk and talk and talk and talk
and have for the last decade,
but if you look carefully in a very narrow
you know I haven't gone into
healthcare or geopolitical.
You know I'm not talking
for the sake of talking
or adding my two cents to
every pop culture situation.
I talk about the things that I know.
Communication in the modern world
usually in a social network environment.
More and more probably now in a voice
environment as I become
fascinated with that platform.
I think it's important to have a skill
and then the next thing that's important
is to understand how you communicate.
You I'm guessing write
now clearly can write.
You know other people can do audio,
other people can do video I think
the self-awareness of how
you're going to communicate
in one of the three mediums of how
people consume content
is massively important
and so what are you
going to talk about and
what's your best way of communicating that
and once you understand that
what is the current distribution
situations of those things.
So if you're good at audio
you need to understand
anchor you need to understand distribution
of podcasts you need to
understand Alexa briefings.
Written word you need to
understand what is happening
on Facebook, and LinkedIn and Medium and
contribution opportunities.
And then video you need
to understand YouTube
and Facebook and Vimeo which reminds me
I still want a Vimeo movie ASAP.
- [Interviewer] But if
everyone has a personal brand
then is there a point in having one?
- Of course it's called supply and demand.
You know.
Everyone has a personal brand,
but having a successful personal brand
is very different.
- [Interviewer] So your first step would
be to know your role basically.
- You have no chance to break through
the supply and demand issue unless
you have something to add.
So you need to figure that out.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so a
lot of entrepreneurs look at
someone like you and me you
know you kept on pushing.
You kept on pushing,
but sometimes you gotta
know when to give and take.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] So what would you tell
an entrepreneur about that?
- You know perseverance and delusion
are kissing cousins right?
They're very close and
I think a lot of people
make the mistake on that and
that is something that is
hard for me to give advice
in a general sense because the only time
when I know how to give the right answer
to this question is when I've spent
at least 15 minutes to three hours
of meaningful time to be like okay
you're delusional you're not good at this.
You've been doing this for three years
and you think you're gonna breakthrough.
You can't sing bro.
You don't know how to sell stuff.
You know my friend.
So I don't think this is the easiest
question to answer in general terms,
but I do structure it as saying
perseverance and delusion are more
similar than people realize.
With the hope that somebody reads this
and says am I delusional or
am I just a couple years
away from breaking through.
You know that's the real
answer to your question.
- [Interviewer] So just use your gut.
- You know I think gut is scary
because if you don't
have good self-awareness
your guts gonna tell you to do it,
but aka you're delusional.
I think use people around you.
Use historical success.
You know and then I
would add one last thing
I would argue I'd rather somebody
continue to preserve around
something they love doing.
Like if you love making ice cream sundaes
and you want to become
the number one expert
on ice cream sundaes with the
hope of opening ice cream sundae stores.
I weirdly would rather you
not all the way make it
kind of live paycheck to paycheck,
but be so happy than go and do law
be miserable and make
a little bit more money
that allows you to take a
vacation or have a fancy car.
So it's a complex question, right.
- [Interviewer] I understand
exactly what you mean.
I was 16 all i wanted to
do was play video games
and write so I write to the newspaper
a cold email I said hire
me I'll work for free.
- Right and to me if you know
now I'm getting to know you.
I'm like hey bro have
you thought about really
getting focused on
e-sports because I think
that's going to be a big
space for the next 20 years.
So like these are the questions and
to me you making $87,000 a
year writing about e-sports
is more attractive than making $210,000
as a consultant in the
way that I view life.
Some could argue to me that they are so
insecure that they need
a Rolex and a BMW and
that's what scratches the itch for them.
I'm okay with that.
I would just argue that if they tasted
what it felt like to make 87 writing about
e-sports and maybe renting an apartment
instead of owning a bigger home.
I mean you know this is
advice I take for myself.
There's a million things I could be doing.
I could own a townhouse in New York City.
I could have a home in Dubai
and Singapore and London
if I was willing to do things
that made me more cash,
but I love doing what I'm doing obviously
for me it worked out because I could
have a little bit of both,
but there's a million
different versions of that.
- [Interviewer] So when you
started VaynerMedia what
was going through your mind?
- To build a marketing and
communications death star.
Which is funny to be in this office.
I call a machine. I call it a death star.
I call it a platform.
I call it an ecosystem.
Call it what you want.
To eat shit for 10 years.
To eat my own dog food the advice
I just gave in the last question.
Spend 10 years loving it.
Grinding to build a platform.
So that I could buy
businesses in my 50s and 60s
and run them through the machine
and create this proportionate
return on the investment.
I can buy Kleenex.
I can buy K-Swiss.
I can buy Aquafina in eight years
and build an incredibly big business
because I spent these 10
years building VaynerX
the holding company that has VaynerMedia,
PureWow the acquisition I made
which is getting myself into publishing.
You know I've been debating starting the
premier Sports Illustrated,
ESPN of e-sports.
So you know these are
the things I think about.
Why would I do that?
Because if I have the number one e-sports
48 million readers each month in 11 years
if I buy a brand a hoodie
company Supreme, an energy drink.
Having that platform is going to help
me build that business, understand?
- [Interviewer] Understand, so it's all
about connecting the dots.
- Connecting the dots.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
So I've been watching your
vlogs voice tech is something
you think is huge so I use
Google Home, I use Alexa
I'm still feeling there is no killer app.
- There is no killer app.
- [Interviewer] So what needs
to be done in this space.
- The killer app needs to come out.
- [Interviewer] So that's just it.
- That's it. That's right.
You need the Pokemon Go
that makes us say wow AR.
I'm trying to think about the iPhone.
Angry Birds that makes us say gaming.
You need the killer app,
but the ecosystem is so young.
I mean this is so early.
- [Interviewer] So we have all
these different walt gardens
we have Google and Amazon and Microsoft.
So how do you think these big
boys should be playing it?
- I think they should continue
to put up walt gardens.
It's far more profitable.
- [Interviewer] Keep going?
- That's how they make money.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- You know I don't think
Google or Facebook,
or LinkedIn or Microsoft or any Apple has
any obligation to society to open
up the data so we have it better.
I don't think that has
anything to do with business.
- [Interviewer] Take a step back
I love the DailyVee's of course.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] So what was the
inspiration to start this and
to really it must be a lot of work.
- You know its not a lot of work,
it's actually been an incredibly
smart strategy to be honest.
You know I live my life.
Somebody documents it.
They post, produce.
I am not egotistical or too romantic.
So I don't really get
involved in post production.
I mean literally I don't even know.
It doesn't take a lot of work at all
which is scary compared
to the impact it has.
It creates a consistent show which works.
It also feeds all my written, audio and
other micro video content.
I mean the fact that
I could put out a clip
on Instagram a couple days ago
that gets a million organic views
and have that branding in that 20-35 demo
that I'm so desperate to have.
The fact that that was just one moment
of me being in Wine Library on a Saturday
giving a 13 year old kid some advice.
That we post edited and chopped up
in post production on my
media team internally.
That's incredible.
Like I think I figured it out.
Macro content at scale,
which then creates micro content at scale.
All of which doesn't do anything to me
other than force me to
actually live my life.
I'm not doing anything today for DailyVee.
I'm living life.
So it's a very interesting
thing that I'm doing
because I'm confusing a lot of people.
I've created an incredible perception
that I spend all of my
time on my personal brand
in a world where I spend none of
my time on my personal brand.
- [Interviewer] Makes sense.
- I'm spending 15 hours a day
being the CEO of VaynerMedia
it's pretty cool I'm very proud
of the model I've created.
I do think in 10 years I will be,
I think when I started it there
was ridicule behind the scenes.
I mean it's a very
narcissistic, Charlton situation
and I'm empathetic to that.
Like who wakes up one morning and
thinks that they deserve to have somebody
following them around 24/7.
That takes a level I understand
why there is some cynicism and pushback.
I'm just fully aware that this is what
a lot of people are
going to do in a decade.
- [Interviewer] You mentioned that
the 20 to 30 year old bracket
is something you're
supremely interested in
so is everyone else ...
- Yes.
But this generation we
are incredibly fickle ...
- Yes.
- We have no loyalty ...
- Correct.
- We don't really care too much ...
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How do brands,
how do companies reach out to?
- By accepting that and realizing
they have to bring value
in a disproportionate way.
- [Interviewer] What values are 25 to 30
years olds looking for?
- A million different things depending
on who the hell they are.
You know inspiration,
motivation, information,
entertainment the same exact thing
the 45 to 60 year olds are looking for
it just comes in a different form.
Humans are humans.
Escapism, utility.
Look at your iPhone.
I ask everyone who is reading this article
to take the front screen of
their telephone and look at it.
Right now the apps on the front screen
of your telephone are
the biggest indication
of what you give a shit
about in the world.
Let me save you some time and
tell you what's on the front
screen of your telephone.
Communication, utility and entertainment.
The way humans work.
So you have to be good at those things.
So why does Venmo work?
It's a utility that brings
them value and saves them time,
just like Uber right?
Why does Spotify and YouTube work
because it's entertainment.
It's called music and television and film.
Why does Snapchat and Instagram
and Facebook and Twitter work?
It's called communication.
We need to communicate we
have to scratch that itch.
I'm very, very old school.
I just understand how to
interpret in new school.
- [Interviewer] So
what's on the home screen
on Gary Vaynerchuk's phone?
- So Gary Vaynerchuk's home screen is like
every single other person
it's disproportionately social
because I'm a media creator and
then it's utility right?
So Resy an app that I'm involved in
which is a restaurant app, right?
Travel, weather like everybody else.
And then Spotify and YouTube.
I mean just slack.
You know the same as everybody.
I have less entertainment.
There's no game.
I don't watch YouTube.
I distribute content.
It's really no different
it's the quickest tell.
I know about somebody in four seconds
if I look at their home screen.
It's incredible.
- [Interviewer] I'll ask
you to look at mine later.
Hopefully you can give
me some great advice.
- I will.
- [Interviewer] So two social
platforms that really trick me
that you have mastered,
Instagram what is the
secret to a great Instagram.
Because Instagram is short snappy people
don't have a lot of attention span
so what is the recipe
for a great Instagram?
- My belief today.
Something that is a snapshot of what's
actually going on in your stomach.
And I say that you can
use the word stomach,
you can use the word
brain, you can use heart.
I think I for example I
am unbelievably motivated
and grateful and I believe that my
motivational quotes work on Instagram
because it's my truth not because
I think motivational quotes work.
For example you know
what works on Instagram?
Incredibly beautiful pictures.
Do you know how many I've
posted in the last four years?
- [Interviewer] Zero.
- Because I don't know how
to take a beautiful picture.
So I don't ask DRock or Babin or
people that could do
that for me to do that
so I could post it.
It's not what comes from my
heart, brain, or stomach.
You know if you are actually an
incredible fitness person and
you understand fitness you know what
does well your fitness content.
Now the fact that you're attractive and
you understand lighting and angles, helps,
but there are tons of people.
You know when I go through my feed or
explore or look at people engaging me.
I'll see somebody DM and I'll say oh that
persons good looking girl or boy
and I'll be like I wonder
how many followers they have?
And the amount of times I click and
they have 450 or 6000.
I'll be like this makes no sense.
Supply and demand,
but also does it come from their soul?
So I think anything can work on Instagram.
Humor, beautiful images, quotes,
micro clips that are insightful.
It's very cliche,
but I genuinely think at this point
because of the maturity of the platform
the only thing that's
breaking through is truth.
- [Interviewer] Fantastic
that's a very good headline.
- I think so.
- [Interviewer] Very
impactful makes me seem like
I know what I'm talking about.
Another one so it's LinkedIn.
- LinkedIn.
- [Interviewer] So people get
confused as hell on LinkedIn.
I love LinkedIn my friends call it
my version of Tinder because I'm
like oh which famous person do I know.
- I love it.
- [Interviewer] So you've obviously
figured out LinkedIn as well.
So tell me how does one maximize LinkedIn?
- LinkedIn is real good for me
because I'm a business man
it's a business environment
and so I think LinkedIn is an incredibly
interesting place for deeper,
longer form content around business.
So Colin on my team my writer
and Sid on my team what
I would call distributor
an architect of our content.
They've spent a lot of time on it
and I give them a big head nod
for my success on LinkedIn.
I mean that's a natural
place for me, right.
I mean to me that's a home run environment
because I have a lot of business content
in my head as you're
interviewing me for this
you can see how natural it comes to me
it's my ethos I don't have to think twice.
I could talk about business
literally 24 hours a day
literally until the day I die and
would not run out of content
because it's my truest self.
It's all I ever thought about.
Literally since the time
I was five years old
it's why I was such a bad student.
I couldn't turn off my head
from thinking about selling and buying
and trading and understanding
why people buy stuff.
I mean why were kids
interested in Garbage Pail Kids
in 1986 that's not what third graders do
they're just interested
in Garbage Pail Kids.
I was interested in why.
So long form content.
Because when you're in LinkedIn and
you're in your Tinder moment of business
you're in that mindset.
You're in your ambitious.
You're in your what you do for a living.
You're in your business mindset.
You're in a very different mindset
when you're on Instagram.
So what I think I'm doing very well
that is very subtle is I create content
for the mindset and they
psychographic nature
of what's happening in there
not the demographic nature.
Let me expand on that.
All of us in this room are
the same fucking person
we're us,
but when we go into six different apps
our brains chemicals are different.
You know Instagram is
escapism for a lot of people.
They're checking out attractive people.
They're looking for a laugh.
They're keeping up with culture.
Your brain is not in the same place on
Instagram as LinkedIn.
- [Interviewer] Of course.
- I make content for that reality.
That is why I have won
more than almost anybody.
I understand that.
And even my own team
doesn't hold a candle to me
in copy and nuance to that subtle trait.
- [Interviewer] So
Twitter's not very big here.
Twitter is fourth after
Instagram, LinkedIn and Facebook
of course now with DT in office
Twitter seems to be
more popular than ever.
- Why? What did you say?
Because?
- [Interviewer] Because of
what's happening in the states.
People are accessing Twitter more.
- To see what Donald Trump says, okay.
Makes sense I understand.
Go ahead.
- [Interviewer] So how should people?
So now that Twitter's coming
up as a reasonable medium
how should people be using it?
How should people be looking at it?
- Twitter was always the
anomaly in social media
because it wasn't a content play it was
a community play and that's why so
many people struggle with Twitter
both media companies and individuals.
It is the platform to listen not talk
and nobody wants to listen.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
I like what you eluded to there.
- Yeah I mean it's the one place where
you can jump into any conversation.
I mean the fact that you can
jump into any conversation.
So on LinkedIn it's super fun for you
to look at Branson or
Cuban or Barbara Cochran
on Twitter you could
literally reply to them
on something they just said
and they'll actually reply to you.
I mean look at every A list personality
99% of them if they're active on Twitter
that is the place to get
an engagement from them
far more than Instagram,
LinkedIn or Facebook.
Including myself.
The way to get me to reply and
see what you're up to is far more likely
to happen on Twitter.
Because it is built for communication
not for distribution of content.
That's why it's failed so many because
everybody wants to put out content
and have people consume it and
impact them for what they have selfishly
behind that content and move on.
But for somebody that is
a quote on quote nobody
Twitter is the place to go.
You start by listening and talking.
It's what I did.
I was a nobody in 2007 on Twitter.
What did I do?
I responded to Leo LaPorte and
Kevin Rose and Pete Cashmore
and more importantly I
searched the word wine
and every single tech nerd that said
I'm going to Napa to
drink wine this weekend
who worked at Salesforce or Microsoft
I just replied and said what
winery are you going to?
And they were like whoa.
Uh I don't know and then I'd reply
well you should go to Whitehall Lane
and then they would look at my profile
and see Wine Library T.V. and
they'd be like thanks dude.
One, by one, by one, by one,
12, 14, 16, 12, 14, 16 hours a day
and then I was a somebody.
Because A. I spent 15
years learning about wine
so I knew where the hell to send them and
B. Because I fucking
bled out of my eyeballs
for 15 hours a day and put in the work.
- [Interviewer] Fantastic.
- And no platform could do
that for you like Twitter.
Because you don't need to
be great at creating content
to get noticed you just have to be
good at replying to information
around your expertise,
but most people don't have the humility
when they're an expert cake maker to
spend three hours a day replying
to people talking about cake on
Twitter because they're fancy.
And that I can even deal with
because you're an expert cake maker
what really pisses me off is aspiring kids
who want to be somebody think their
time is so valuable that they can't put in
four fucking hours replying
to people on Twitter.
- [Interviewer] I'm inspired.
Okay oh dear we don't have much time.
Okay last one.
So thoughts on influence and movement.
It's big I mean I work a lot with brands
so every time I speak to a union leader
how can we gauge influences.
- KOL's.
- [Interviewer] What's a KOL?
- Key opinion leaders.
- [Interviewer] Oh is
that what they call them?
- That's the Asian,
that's China's terminology
that I think is bleeding into
SouthEast Asia's terminology,
but anyway influencers, KOL's go ahead.
- [Interviewer] So what do
brands need to earn influence.
- Give them their brand and
get the hell out of their way
and as long as their not doing
something egregious approve the content.
They know their audience way
better than the brand does.
So if they want to take the bottle of
water and put it on
their head and do this.
That's going to work for their audience
because that influencer knows that.
And no brand manager should be like no, no
our brand never goes on a humans head.
If that's the case then run print ads
and get out of influencer marketing.
- [Interviewer] So influencer
marketing is brand new.
How do ...
- Influencer marketing is not brand new.
Influencer marketing has been around since
John Wayne was putting cigarettes
in his mouth for Lucky Strike.
It's endorsement.
What's new is the long tail of endorsement
and the gross under pricing nature.
Beyonce is over priced,
Shmeyonce is under priced.
And scale.
40, 400, 4000 influencers for one brand
versus one celebrity endorsement
George Clooney, right.
That's new.
And that's something they
don't understand yet,
but it is absolutely under priced
and has always been under priced.
- [Interviewer] How do brands know
what to look for in an influencer?
- Run analytics.
Look at their audience, segmentation,
understand their distribution.
Make a qualitative and
quantitative decision
like they do with anything
else that distributes information.
- [Interviewer] So right now brands
are not getting it right?
- It's not that brands
are not getting it right.
It's that agency partners
are not positioning it right
to brands to figure out how to use it.
Because it's awfully
difficult to make money
in influencer marketing the way that media
companies want to make money.
- [Interviewer] Okay well
we do have one more time so
this is for me personally.
- Okay no worries.
- [Interviewer] I started off in print.
Print's been my life I still
hold it up above many things,
but is my industry dying?
What's going to happen?
- If you think your industry is that paper
and print on that paper
is the Holy Grail, sure.
If you think your
industry is communicating
through the written word
it's never been a better time.
- [Interviewer] But my (mumbles)
harder than it's ever been.
- For the?
- [Interviewer] Print guys yeah.
- Sure as it should be you know why
you can write directly on medium.
- [Interviewer] True.
- Distribution has been commoditized.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- When distribution has been commoditized
the creators have the leverage.
The IP has the leverage.
Star Wars 13 can come
out directly on Netflix.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- It could.
It maybe won't, but it could.
Right.
Distribution has been commoditized.
The internet is the middle man.
- [Interviewer] So for the
writer looking to make (mumbles)
12, 14, 16.
- You should write everywhere
as often as possible.
You're one article away
from your career changing.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
Interview is done.
Thank you so much for your time Mr. Gary.
- Such a pleasure.